my spaceship runs on blood gone sexual
dude look at this dog acting is that joe
exotic there's one really cool effect
i've never seen before
this episode of vfx artist react is
brought to you by skillshare stick
around to the end to see how you can get
two free months of premium membership
hey guys welcome back to another episode
of visual effects artist react i got
some hot clips today for you guys we're
gonna look at friends
today we watch friends and break down
our favorite moments do you know the
monkey and friends with cg the whole
time
all right let's hop into it what's the
first video on the docket
oh i know what this is oh there's a
gladiator what a good movie huak and
phoenix jocken
the p is a hard p hyenas
[Laughter]
[Applause]
whoa okay wow that's how you just took a
swipe at real i mean that was that was
compositing exactly that was compositing
this isn't the era where you don't do
this stuff in 3d you have to get actual
footage of tigers and actual footage of
your scene and then put the two together
somehow yeah this is before pai's life
like the whole background is probably
composited too right i think above the
fence line there like i think they're
actually in an arena but everything
above the railing of the arena might be
added in
[Applause]
the compositing looks really good that's
pretty good but i mean we can tell
something's off there the first most
obvious one is that the contrast doesn't
match is it less saturated the sunlight
is warmer on the russell crow plate
versus the tiger plate it looks like the
lighting is off by like 90 degrees or so
you can see the pillar in the background
the shadows going away from us but the
light's coming from the back side of the
tiger you can see how the tiger's face
shadow is going across the front of its
neck how do you think they film this
tiger though do you think they filmed
them at this exact location from the
same camera angle or did they film it in
some other sort of studio i think they
filmed the tigers here because there's
like some really solid like dirt
interaction too but notice the guy in
the foreground that's a fake foreground
element right there so they're trying to
you know still maintain that kind of
like visceral real filming style so they
just have a very blurry out of focus
shot of the guy's shoulder that it was
definitely not filmed at the same time
this has been comp over the footage yeah
they had to like purposely make the shot
worse to make it feel real
this only speaks to the issue of when
you don't have the same elements on set
at the same time it's cool it looks
pretty real and especially for when this
came out it's definitely very photo real
but you definitely get a bit of
detachment where the tiger swipes at the
guy and the guy doesn't even jump or
like hear the sound it definitely feels
like two people filmed at separate times
but visually speaking because they're
all real elements it still looks pretty
realistic especially for when this came
out now there's a shot coming up here
where it gets a little messy with
shutter speeds and motion blur so tiger
motion of dudes in motion and then we
have a panning camera but the motion
blur doesn't change at all there's no
motion blur in the background despite
the camera's whip panning yeah and the
characters in the foreground that are
sticking with the camera are still
motion blurred so this shot and the
camera is locked off on a tripod so they
punch it in and they add the motion in
post but it really stands out to our
eyes that for example russell crowe's
armored kilt right here it stays in the
same spot on the frame but there's these
long motion blurred lines as if it's
moving and it's weird because it
shouldn't be motion blur like that if
it's kind of occupying the same space it
would only be motion blurred like that
if it's moving that far each frame and
it's not meanwhile that background is
whipping across the frame and is crystal
clear yes
i think overall what they're doing here
is a really simple and approachable
method for getting a tiger in your shots
it's not
that complicated when it comes to the
post side of things the filming side of
it however yeah i just don't do what
you're asking to do every time
blood machines so there's a song by
carpenter brute called turbo killer and
these guys made a music video for it
that people really liked and they're
like what if we made a movie but it was
half an hour long and we put on
kickstarter and we still made it and had
a bunch of crazy visuals well that's
blood machines
that reminds me of the drop ship from
halo one yeah but look at the chomper
ship cause the ships are kind of living
things also in this world hence blood
machines hence blood machines
dude the dripping water and everything
bringing the shot to life man look at
how much like gritty detail there is
oh this like normal ass dude flies this
ship i thought i was like a huge like
orc alien dude he's gonna step out it's
like no it's like this kind of like
freaking english postman
hey
these women are other ship cores we can
still heal her
i love the laser effects how they linger
yeah that's what to say that was that
was pretty sweet dude the glow on her
face wait is that real glow or i think
oh yeah
there's one really cool effect that i've
never seen before probably missed it
maybe you didn't so they're giving the
impression that this is shot on film so
film you know it's an actual chemical
reaction you know photons come in hit
these like silver crystals they break
down in different ways and that's how
you get your film look film is also
susceptible to things like x-rays and
like various like cosmic rays and things
like that the film itself has artifacts
where you can see like particles from
this energy weapon have pierced the film
and left little trails like the kind you
see from like particle colliders it
almost looks like hair got left on a
film when it got scanned in it's about
mimicking the process of having to
actually have filmed this object i
noticed that i didn't think about the
chemistry element behind it but maybe
they took some radioactive stuff and
shot it at film for plates
wow this is such a bizarre movie if you
think this is bizarre wait is it about
to get more bizarre this movie is very
french it's the best way i can describe
it so what what are we about to see nico
it's time to perform a dark ritual
is that the spaceship spirit i think it
is
it's like crawling along the surface
it's the matrix bug effect it's the
beetle from the mummy effect that must
just be a fun displacement map trick
right yeah it's almost like you have to
like render it once and then just like
map it and displacement map it
oh boy it's gonna get sexual now
yeah that's what i thought
all right i told you this is very french
we're calling this my spaceship runs on
blood parentheses gone sexual
this is how spaceships are made kids
[Music]
blood machines there's the actual intro
15 minutes into the into the movie the
title finally shows up
wow
this is what it looks like when you're
on the internet yeah
this is what happens when you pay for
the fastest internet
dude like the way they handle the color
processing is so cool it's so well done
there's some incredible visuals in that
film yeah this is on shutter if you guys
want to check it out
you're so close to 4 million subscribers
so please subscribe and if you're the
lucky four millionth subscriber we will
actually hand deliver the deed to our
whole studio to you along with
everything we own will belong to you if
you're a four million subscriber so
please subscribe thank you love you we
stand for something and today i watched
in shame as all that was portrayed wait
are those animals talking this movie
came out in 1995 and these are talking
dogs this is the most realistic cg dog
i've ever seen
george miller the man who made babe made
mad max
then he followed up with babe 2 picking
the city followed by happy feet followed
by happy feet 2 followed by mad max fury
road
[Laughter]
are you all right well i wouldn't call
that a bite myself so wasn't this where
they they basically it's they're real
animals but they're just doing uh like
jaw replacements right no that's a
puppet that's a puppet yeah that's a
puppet sheep so is that pig a puppet
that's a puppet for sure
so how do you make an animal talk well
obviously you can do puppets you can
make them chew peanut butter which is
how they make horses talk pretty often
but in this case they did a technique
that's really really straightforward and
it's used all the time in filmmaking
these days so i made a 3d model and they
tracked it to the animal's head by hand
that's all manual tracking i know
there's like no tracking markers on this
stuff yeah so something the computer is
just like kind of trying to keep it all
tracked to the head frame by frame doing
it by hand and they basically took that
image from the film of the animal and
they projected it onto the 3d model and
then they could move that 3d model and
therefore distort the animal's face the
catch however is the animals are opening
their mouths so the inside of the mouth
is actually a 3d model being revealed as
you know the pieces move around the
other tricky thing is the dogs are
usually going like this
and not you know keeping their mouth
shut because that's their dogs that's
how they work they have to paint out the
tongue yeah or like when the when the
head sideways and it opens its mouth
they have to paint in the background
because it reveals the background you
know otherwise the dog's head would be
blocking what kind of tools were they
using for that way back then yes
software they're using oh my god you can
see the painted out background right
here so you can see the original shot of
the pig like moving its head and you can
see the spot where they have to
reconstruct the background because when
the pig opens its mouth you'll see the
background through it so they're
literally tracking the plates of the
people and stuff through that dude you
know that's so crazy that movie came out
like what 26 27 years ago and that's the
exact same method we use today to paint
stuff back in still doing the exact same
thing this whole movie is animals
talking i don't think a human could have
done this
well because like i was making the point
in that video talking about call of the
wild about like the dog having this
expressive like determination and
whatnot but the scene between the two
dogs in this movie i was seeing real
acting between those two dogs and that's
probably because they're actually acting
with their eyes digitally i don't know
it worked for me here i heard that with
call of the wild that harrison ford
refused to leave los angeles i also
imagine that had something to play with
the animal like with it being a dog he
probably wouldn't have sat there and
done all the takes over and over to be
with the dog harvey thinks that when you
are sacrificing your locations you can't
go to alaska you can't film with real
dogs all for an actor the actor's
ruining your movie it's like they're not
serving the film the film's serving in
the interest of an actor yeah but people
will go see a movie with harrison ford
in it
i don't think anyone saw it insert
famous actor i'm just saying chris
hemsworth there we go call of the wild
featuring thor
so this this whole image mapping and
face warping thing has been used in
other films let's take a look at where
the wild thing is oh i never saw this
movie you never saw this this is a
really good movie yeah i missed it i
don't know i don't know i don't know
anything but i do like sleeping in a
real pile i mean this looks really good
man like the light and the fur and it
doesn't look cg at all well those aren't
full cg monsters are they no they look
like costumes they look like mascots
they're emoting like real people do
they're really creepy nico nico do the
porous stretch they do actually
to do it all practically you get these
amazing shots amazing cinematography the
acting so much easier but you have these
facial expressions that you got to deal
with and so they're just doing the same
thing they did in babe where they 3d
track basically the monster's face
that's recreated in cg and then a 3d
model and they project what they
captured on film back onto that 3d model
and then you can move that 3d model to
distort the image so like the eyes there
i think his whole face there is cg
including his like the hair on the top
of his head oh no on the top of his head
that's real so you're saying it's like
it's a real practical head and just the
face right here is being replaced yes
you know the bird guy for example just
readjusting the edges of the beak and
the eyes like it's so much cheaper and
easier to film it and then just like you
know do a little tweak on the expression
and you don't have to re-render anything
you don't want to like do a full-on
re-light you don't want to like match
stuff it's just a little image
distortion and you call it a day well
there's a lot of implicit value in
having like a real practical costume
like that on set on the one hand it
gives everyone a shared sense of what
we're seeing gives the cinematographer a
better idea of how to frame up the shot
and get the best lighting possible for
that costume and you can come up with
new shots on the spot but the child of
the the bird guy carrying the rocks
right there there's no cg in that shot
and that's a shot like you don't have to
worry about doing any face remapping
that's a shot you can just pick up like
you can just get it and it doesn't cost
you any extra money outside of you know
the extra couple minutes it takes you to
get the shot contrast that with how this
movie would be made today they'd
probably be full cg monsters i i almost
guarantee they'd probably look just as
good as they do here but it would
require so much more effort in my
opinion and there's a big risk that they
probably wouldn't look good yeah well
even if they look good it doesn't matter
because it starts to get to this point
where you look at it and you're like
it's all cg it would become call of the
wild whereas you watch this and it's
like this is very plausible you know
there's stories and there's movies where
it's okay for vfx to look like cg where
it's like i'm basically just watching a
fancy cartoon but when you can make it
look completely real it's a magic trick
and it takes you to another place it
wows you you can't take your eyes off
the screen in a movie like this it's
just it's so mind-blowing to just have
it be real and to see it be real right
in front of you even if it is cg and you
can't tell it just looks so good where's
the line between having to do it in cg
versus being able to do it because i
feel like most filmmakers agree with us
and that like doing it this way is the
superior way now what if these were the
incredible hulk
incredible
well i think what you're saying is
you're gonna given a script a young boy
travels to an island filled with
incredible hulks how do you do this
practically is there a way to do it
practically i say no there isn't unless
your hulk is like a reasonable size it's
like no obviously you're writing
something that's not possible to do your
imagination is boundless but filmmaking
is not that's very poetic yeah
let's take a moment here let's talk
about learning in particular let's talk
about skillshare which is the sponsor of
today's vfx artist react video 2020 so
far has been a little crazy a lot of us
have been spending a lot of time
isolated and what better time than when
you are spending time alone to try to
pick up a new skill to try to pick up a
new talent to invest yourself in some
education so skillshare is a website
that fosters an academic community where
professionals are making lessons and
videos to teach you a new skill whether
it's something like motion graphics and
animation to music mixing and music
engineering there's a whole lot of great
stuff there i myself am a fan of a
certain guy named jordy van de poot he's
a crazy filmmaker who knows all about
adobe premiere he knows all the details
like he knows every single feature that
that program has it's been actually kind
of an eye-opener to learn some things
that i didn't know about another great
thing about skillshare is the the lesson
structure is built in a way where things
are broken up into kind of bite-sized
chunks you're not sitting there for
three hours trying to slog your way
through a class it's structured for you
to work with it on your own time very
convenient skillshare is also very
affordable if you subscribe for an
annual membership it's less than ten
dollars a month so if you would like to
invest some time in yourself and develop
some new skills down in the description
below is a link to skillshare and if you
click on that you will get two free
months of premium memberships so it's
definitely worth checking out spend some
time bettering your skills honing your
edge against the competition so go check
it out
thank you so much for watching these
videos we love going through this
footage and breaking stuff down like
this and just the fact that you are here
watching this and find this interesting
well it's it's the best thing we're so
happy you are watching the show right
now so don't forget to check us out
again next saturday where we will return
with even more clips